what do you understand this idea this
idea here going up or down idea what
would want to be more when I have more
finesse and precision as we talk about
it so we're going to start nice and
simply with the visuals and then we're
going to go more towards abstraction
okay so here we go we'll start the top
if I had something remember said
increasing or decreasing or station and
it's going up like this okay
if I want to pick a particular point on
here why stay right in the middle here
at an x value x equals a okay
I'm just looking in a particular spot at
that spot I would say the sign of the
gradient is the sign of the gradient
because going on the sign is positive
right that's what positive gradient
means because we just find break it to
be rise over run not
okay so positive value means sure enough
it is rising okay now we can say at x
equals a and x is forget introduce this
calculus language and say a positive
gradient means that the function as a
halt that point is increasing that's
what we're going to classify this as
okay so I'm going to say less and less
off there's a positive gradient and I'm
going to say more off there the function
is increasing they're equivalent but
it's a different nuance it's wiggling
yeah that's me I can do better than that
if I want it's moving on it okay now let
me really really find here right I can
combine all of this the same most
succinctly right I'm making a statement
about the gradient and it's valued at a
at X equal to a so if F is they never
apply function
what would I usually write you indicate
the great
and actually now I should I could write
F dash X that would make the gradient
function at any variable spot but I'm
actually interested only in one spot
namely that point right there right in
fact that's the whole point of calculus
right remember no point of first
principles is what I can do more than
gradient from here to here I can do
gradient as the limit approaches zero at
a point it's a powerful idea and we're
going to include it here so I'm just
gonna say F dash X I'm gonna say F dash
a that's the gradient at a it's positive
so I'm going to say it's ready Monsieur
are you happy with that now from then
you can start to see the pattern if
that's what it looks like to be
increasing and if I have another kind of
similar wavy function like that and I
pick a point then I say let's come back
hey I would say this side of the
derivative e is we can do this quick and
I'll write the site is maybe we're going
to classify this as decreasing at that
particular point it's administration I
would use to indicate that most
succinctly would be okay
you could do the last word don't you
tell me what to write I want something
to draw on here something like a
straight line right now by the way I'm
gonna again just like I have up here I'm
going to draw a kind of a weakly
straight line because I'm just
interested in a particular point right
of obviously a straight line will have a
gradient of zero all the way along right
but you can have a gradient of zero just
it is one spot a single infinitesimally
small spot like that when you are not
going up not going down it would be an
infinitely small spot like that once
you've identified it you could say
uh-huh
by that point what's the gradient here
zero
which means that is neither increasing
nor decreasing outward of twins movie
station stationary with an a by the way
not stationary really which is this
stationary really okay because he is
from a river now here again I want to
make a nice concise statement right I
get about half touch a what can I say
about it
okay now simple ideas right simple
simple ideas and yet watch as we apply
the